hey david is critical race theory
actually dangerous like right winger say
or is it just kind of reductive yeah
this is good you know
the i've issued many critiques about
critical race theory on this show
i don't think it's dangerous um i think
as a general
concept one can always argue being
uninformed
can have negative consequences and so
you could say
well if you believe that no matter how
fast you drive
you won't get hurt if you get into a car
crash yeah that's a belief that's
dangerous in a very specific and
tangible way
when it comes to critical race theory
i wouldn't apply the word dangerous i i
do think however
that um critical race theory
could potentially be harmful to race
relations between individuals that's
number one
i do think critical race theory is
reductive
in the way that it deals with race
over many other factors that affect how
people relate to each other in modern
society
um and i've i've talked before about how
you know critical theories like critical
race theory
heavily are supported by ideas of
post-modernism
and post-structuralism and this is not
me going all jordan peterson talking
about
post-modernism and that that's not it's
not this vague uh
critique and i'm not saying uh anything
beyond what i'm actually
saying but the basis of critical race
theory
and the genesis of some of the ideology
and post-modernism and
post-structuralism
relies on
the ideas in some combination
that reality is socially constructed
it's it's sort of an attack on
empiricism and it's a propping up of the
idea that
any reality any notion any analysis
could be just as real as any other and
in some cases taken to a very you know
extreme place
uh could be deserves equal footing
in discussions about how society should
be organized
um and then one of the other aspects of
critical race theory that i think is
very problematic now by
by the way if you're going to email me
you're going to say david that
one piece doesn't apply to all of
critical race theory fine
i'm i'm talking in generalities about
things that exist within
uh enclaves of critical race theory one
of the really concerning things i see
are very very um
casual claims
levied against anyone who challenges
aspects of critical race theory
that merely by challenging critical race
theory
you are a white supremacist you are
racist
you are an oppressor you were part of
the problem we saw this earlier this
week with the story about
the seattle pride event some pride event
in seattle
that was only going to charge a fee to
white people
how do you identify which those people
are i don't know and they weren't
calling it an admission fee they were
calling it a reparations fee
to get around saying the admission
is is depending on race um
and then when some members of the
seattle city council said this this this
is bad this really doesn't make any
sense
they were accused of doing violence
by critiquing the plan of only charging
the reparations fee
to the white attendees that's a that's a
non-starter for me
that's the opposite of rational inquiry
and uh so back to the question is
critical race theory actually dangerous
i think just about any idea if taken far
enough you could
justify and say it would be dangerous in
this way
i think that it's incomplete i think
it's reductive and i think it's
counterproductive over the long term
to both race relations and achieving
real equality
under the law and and in society
which i think is an important add-on
because many areas we have equality
under the law
but for socio-cultural reasons we don't
have actual equality that's my sense
let me know your thoughts if you ever
feel like you just
don't have enough time to read all the
books you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills each one down into an
e-book or
audiobook that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from
10 different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video